we've increased uh disinformation
research and tracking we're flagging
problematic posts
for facebook uh that spreads this
information
now this is a state-sponsored enterprise
if you don't think that that is
authoritarianism i don't know what to
tell you that is authoritarianism this
is extremely dangerous stuff
if once again you can label all of your
political opponents extremist
unworthy of public debate then you can
militarize private institutions to stop
them and this is exactly what the white
house basically announced they were
doing yesterday this is an
unbelievable thing it really is it
should scare the hell out of everyone
right left and center because if the
trump administration had said we've
called up facebook
and we've told them we think that they
are distributing this information
and we need them to take down that
misinformation right now for the good of
the republic
and also if they don't you know we do
have oversight power with regard to
facebook
and now democrats have been making these
sorts of signals for a while you'll
recall that dianne feinstein called the
senator from from california
called mark zuckerberg before a senate
committee and she said if you don't stop
this sort of stuff we will
which is a direct and open threat that
we are only going to give you a level of
immunity
as long as you do what we want which
does make them a quasi-state actor in
the sense that they are now
operating at the best of a government
and government cannot use state actors
or quasi-state actors private
institutions that are operating under
the under the
explicit direction of the government in
order to violate your rights
and the government does not have the
power
of for example unreasonable search and
seizure so if the government hires a
private contractor
and says i want you to break into that
guy's house and look in his house they
are now
a government contractor or if they say
you know what if you don't
if unless you break into that guy's
house and sir and ransack is safe
we are probably going to prosecute you
the government would be the actor in
that particular scenario the government
is verging very closely on that when
they say things like
we are directly telling facebook what
kind of content we want to come down
that is extremely extremely dangerous
whether i agree with the kind of content
that they're attempting to take down
or not and as we'll see the reality is
that whatever the left declares
misinformation very often is not
misinformation so yesterday
the surgeon general of the united states
blamed big tech
for covered misinformation they said oh
well you know if big tech had just
cracked down on covered misinformation
there'd be less vaccine hesitancy okay
let's be clear about something
people who are vaccine hesitant are
vaccine hesitant for a wide variety of
reasons
one of those reasons is the public
health debacle that has been the
messaging
from the biden administration the trump
administration was no great shakes when
it came to
public health information there were a
lot of conflicting messages from
the fauci no one should wear a mask to
the patchy everyone should wear a mask
but the body administration has not only
been no better in many ways they've been
worse
since the advent of the body
administration anthony fauci has said
that if you get a vaccine
you still can't take off your mask he's
still suggesting right now that
three-year-olds ought to be wearing
masks around in public which is patently
crazy
and so all of this creates vaccine
hesitancy and then when you have the
biden administration
pause j and j the j j vaccine after six
cases of some sort of rare blood
clotting disorder after seven million
doses a lot of people go wait hold up a
second you know the risk to me on covet
it ain't that great it looks like there
might be a risk to me from the vaccine
so maybe i'll wait now
i'm a huge advocate of the vaccines i
think they are mirror i think they're
miraculous in nearly every way
i see no reason why i should inject my
seven five or one year old with the
vaccine
at this point like they're not they're
not subject to serious risk from coven
and it's up to the adults to get
vaccinated kids have never been at
serious risk from covid statistically
speaking
kids are more likely to be killed by a
lightning strike in the united states
than they are to die of covid
something like 311 people under the age
of 18 total in the united states have
died during the entire
coveted pandemic compared with well over
600 000 americans
of other age groups who have died most
of them in the older age range okay but
putting that aside here is the point
much of what has been distributed about
kova that has been misinformation has
been coming
directly from your government anthony
thatcher was saying overtly false things
repeatedly on a wide variety of topics
ranging from schools should stay closed
to don't wear a mask two you need to
wear a mask even after you're vaccinated
right like that that sort of stuff is
going out so
should the administration of the united
states be the
body that determines what facebook
should leave up and what facebook should
take down here's the surgeon general of
the united states blaming big tech for
not taking down what the white house
wanted them to take down
modern technology companies have enabled
misinformation to poison our information
environment with little accountability
to their users
they've allowed people who intentionally
spread misinformation what we call
disinformation to have extraordinary
reach
they've designed product features such
as like buttons
that reward us for sharing emotionally
charged content
not accurate content and their
algorithms tend to give
us more of what we click on pulling us
deeper and deeper into a well
of misinformation hey first of all the
idea that confirmation bias
only exists because of facebook is nuts
confirmation bias exists when a liberal
new yorker
subscribes to the new york times it's
confirmation bias when when
biden fans watch cnn or msnbc that is
confirmation bias confirmation bias
is an inevitable fact of life okay and
people tend to seek out news
that they agree with from sources that
they already agree with okay that's a
negative it's why
on my show i've recommended many times
they listen to this show and then you
listen to shows that disagree
with me and you see who you like better
and who you think is telling you the
truth more
i've noticed that many shows disagree
with me do not provide the same sort
of notification of their own bias but
having the surgeon general of the united
states blame facebook
for covet misinformation and for vaccine
hesitancy is crazy
it's the exact same tactic that the that
the democratic party took in the
aftermath of 2016 when they suggested
the real reason hillary clinton lost was
because of facebook
it was not because hillary clinton was a
crappy candidate it's because
misinformation and disinformation on
facebook the reason they said this is
because they want to bring
facebook under their control they wish
to bring big tech under their control
they wish to use these as instruments of
the democratic party and if they can do
so informally
then they can effectively end around the
first amendment of the united
states by weaponizing institutions as
governmental agents
that's what they are attempting to do
here jin saki made this absolutely clear
yesterday
i mean this is wild authoritarian
garbage here's jen saki saying
you know what we've been doing we've
been actually notifying facebook what we
think is is
disinformation and telling them to take
it down that is
you really want the white house doing
that you want the white house going to
like if the white house came
to the new york times and said we need
you to take down that story it's
disinformation
do you think the new york times would do
it obviously not
if the biden white house came to us here
at daily wire and they said you know
that story that you have up
we think it's disinformation take it
down we might evaluate whether it is in
fact disinformation but we would then
use our own independent judgment and
taking it down we wouldn't take the
white house's word for it
the white house is attempted and the
white house doesn't have power over us
the white house has a lot more power
over for example facebook than it does
over our our news website
but here is jen saki pretty much openly
admitting
that the power of the white house is now
being used to leverage private companies
into subverting free dissemination of
information
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office
we're flagging problematic posts for
facebook uh that spreads this
information
we're working with doctors and medical
professionals to connect
uh two connected medical experts with
popular with popular who are popular
with their audiences with
uh with accurate information and boost
trusted content
i mean this is insane they're basically
saying we want to run
these social media platforms from the
white house
from the white house and if you don't
let us well then i mean
i'm not sure we can hold back the
anti-trust regulators guys i'm not sure
we can
and barack obama did some of the same
stuff with regard to corporate america
in the immediate aftermath
of the of the economic crash of
2007-2008
he famously said to a bunch of banking
ceos i'm the only thing that stands
between
the mob and you and they're they're out
there holding pitchforks you need to do
what i want
you know using the power of the
government to force private industries
to do what you want them to do makes
them quasi state actors
and removes the defense that these are
private actors who can do what they want
because they obviously
can no longer do what they want it makes
that defense very very tenuous
hey the hhs released a full statement
yesterday on what technology platforms
can do strengthen the monitoring of
misinformation quote
platforms should increase staffing of
multilingual content moderation teams
and improve the effectiveness of machine
learning algorithms in languages other
than english
since non-english language
misinformation continues to proliferate
platforms should also address
misinformation in live streams
which are more difficult to moderate due
to their temporary nature and the use of
audio
and video prioritize early detection of
misinformation super spreaders and
repeat offenders and impose clear
consequences for accounts that
repeatedly violate platform policies and
who determines who determines what is
misinformation the white house
this white house trump's like who's
white house who determines what's
misinformation
the fact-checking apparatus that is
solely run at this point by members of
the left
factcheck.org which is always willing to
grant a half true
rating to anything a democrat says but a
four pinocchio
wholly untrue statement to openly true
things that people on the right say
and in the in the area of information
there has to be open discourse
otherwise the truth doesn't come out if
it had been up to the
biden white house let's say let's say
biden president last year
okay and the biden white house would
have been pushing very hard presumably
for facebook to take down quote-unquote
misinformation
about the covet lab leak theory okay
that in fact they didn't even need to
many of these technology platforms
were banning people and censoring people
for doing just that for speculating
that the covet virus started in a lab
leak well now it turns out according to
the washington post
that the who said it will fix several
unintended errors in a joint report with
china on the origins of the culvert
crisis
and we'll look into other possible
discrepancies in response to questions
from the washington post the who is
changing
the virus sequence ids associated with
three of the 13 early patients listed in
the chart in the report and we'll
clarify
the first family cluster was not linked
to the juanan seafood market in wuhan a
spokesman said
so the entire narrative that this thing
started in wet market and wuhan was
nonsense from the beginning the wbho
covered it up and now the who is
uncovering it up but
if the informational determination had
been completely cut down last year you'd
never find out about this
of course the danger of people
controlling these streams of information
is extraordinary remember for years we
were treated to the idea that the steele
dossier might in fact be fact
and now it turns out of course that the
steele dossier was sheer patent nonsense
that was come up with
by a a kind of discredited spy on behalf
of the hillary clinton campaign
laundered through fusion gps but for for
years that was reported
on these platforms as true so you're
going to trust these platforms to
determine
what's true and what's not true and more
importantly you're gonna trust
government actors to tell
these platforms what is true and what is
not true
there's an entire article in new york
magazine today by t.a frank
titled the steele dossier was a case
study in how reporters get manipulated
to pick the worst press failure of the
past half decade would be a daunting
assignment but the coverage of the
steele dossier would have to be high on
any list
the document penned by former british
intelligence agent christopher steele
was commissioned in 2016 by the private
research firm fusion gps
in turn working for the presidential
campaign of hillary clinton the aim was
to dig up dirt on donald trump
especially regarding any ties he might
have had to russia
steel delivered alleging a long-standing
conspiracy between trump and the kremlin
and offering details that proved to be
as unfounded as they were spectacular
although they were almost certainly
species these claims spawned countless
news stories including
at new york magazine and prompted
government investigations into possible
ties between moscow
and trump the steele dossier is just one
recent instance of the media presenting
the public with information that
originated in a vast and opaque industry
of private spies and operatives for hire
who do business without all the rules
and ethics of traditional media outlets
but who often inject their version of
events into the mainstream press by
feeding tips and scoops to reporters
and this is what happened with the
steele dossier for example now we are
finding out by the way
that when the tech platforms shut down
all the talk about hunter biden
we're now finding out according to
politico
that last summer in the middle of the
summer federal officials in delaware
already
had enough information to seek search
warrants and issue grand jury subpoenas
in the hunter biden criminal
investigation last summer
if the new york time if the new york
post mentioned that a month before the
election they were kicked off the tech
platforms
okay this is extremely dangerous stuff
and again
it is it is ends justify the means kind
of thinking
donald trump had to go this justified
not only overt misinformation like the
seal dossier
and and the russian ramp up and all of
that it justified bans on the new york
post
a month before the election cycle and it
justifies the white house now
telling these tech platforms what they
can leave on and what they have to take
off
if you don't think that that is
authoritarianism i don't know what to
tell you that is authoritarianism
it is authoritarian it is state-run in
the same way that the chinese government
props up full corporations and then
steps in and de-lists them from the new
york stock exchange
when it sees fit to do so if private
companies in the united states are
subjected to the regulatory oversight of
the people who are telling them
what to do with their actual content
moderation now this is a state-sponsored
enterprise
and now you have to start wondering who
is actually running the show is this
free and fair competition
is this free and open dissemination
information or is this a backdoor
violation
of the first amendment in the name of
strike bear democracy and stopping the
nazis who live next door
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment